Allen you and I have been talking about
Lamarque for years now we've taught
courses on it together and I find myself
wondering as we come to this occasion if
you could say a little bit about why
this Gospels been important in your own
life and study the action pace in the
Gospel of Mark just the vivid immediacy
of it is just compelling to me okay I I
love the way Jesus keeps coming and
keeps coming and there's not much time
to sit back because of it always
relentlessly moving forward and so
that's one of the reasons another is
just the the absence of words relative
to the other Gospels makes for focus on
the deeds and and I find I find Jesus
deeds in this gospel compelling as well
and and my questions kind of like that
on a larger scale how how do you see
this gospel as a helpful book for the
church in our time my suspicion is that
and many people share this sufficient
that marks actually the first one to
write a gospel to start with there's
good news about Jesus Christ that's what
gospel means this is good news he's the
first one to say alright let's tell the
whole story from the baptism through the
resurrection and so I think he's a great
gift to the church and that he set the
idea of gospel for all of us and I think
in some ways while he while he writes
the worst Greek of any of the Gospel
writers he writes the most interesting
story that it's it's lively it's him
it's cleverly put together it's put
together in such a way that it piques
our interest but also in such a way that
it invites our discipleship it invites
our faith and I suspect if I were to
start a disciples class and say all
right how do you begin to understand
what it is to follow this man Jesus I'd
start with mark yeah so let's start with
Mark and let's start on mark we're going
to talk today the about the first one
and a half two and a half chapters two
chapters in six verses what's going on
what can you tell us about kind of
verses 1 1 through 3 6 well the first
thing that somebody reading it now
notices and we're we're here on January
9 so we're just coming off Christmas and
epiphany and the first thing you notice
is there's no birth story
and so mark moves from an introductory
sentence to John the Baptist in the
wilderness shouting and then on to
rapid-fire episodes of Jesus's life and
so a lot gets done in those two chapters
it we move from Jesus picking up two
disciples and then two more on a beach
through a series of miracles that that
just start to reveal about him and show
who he is and and over the course of
those miracles and is moving forward and
is getting into a little tussle here and
there with the with the Jewish leaders
people start to be compelled by him and
they start to follow him so first it's a
the healing of somebody with a demon in
the synagogue in chapter 1 and then it's
a man who is paralyzed in chapter 2 and
then it's sitting around with tax
collectors and sinners and getting in
some trouble for it and we we see
through what Jesus does in these early
chapters we see through what he does to
who he is and people start to take note
of that it's it's sort of the mark's
word immediately keeps coming back
because he's doing things so closely on
one another
back-to-back on one another so jesus
immediately does this and he immediately
dashes to the synagogue then he
immediately ends up in capernaum yeah
it's like a kid telling a story and
immediately and their to them and then
then dad and then yeah yeah yeah and and
so by the time we get to the end of this
section jesus is a very very popular
character and Jewish leaders are engaged
with him by this time so that so that he
is a little bit becoming a little bit of
an M&M is's to them through these
episodes and that's a lot to get done in
two let's circle back for a minute of
the very first verse which I've puzzled
the bottle out and let me try something
on you and see what you think
the very first verse is this is the
beginning of the gospel of Jesus the
Messiah the Son of God and for the first
we won't say how many years for many
years in my life
I assume that this was the introduction
to
introduction that is that mark says this
is the beginning of the gospel and then
for the next verses he talks about John
the Baptist calling the disciples
preaching the gospel end of the
beginning then we go on with the gospel
itself in in the in the last few years
I'd begun to suspect that Mark who has
no idea what the history of gospel right
is going to be sits down and says I'm
going to write a book called the
beginning of the gospel that this whole
thing from 1 1 to 16 8 is the beginning
of the gospel and that what he's setting
up is a kind of prologue to a story that
will continue in the life of the church
and in the life of believers and so the
right word for this is really not the
gospel by markets the beginning of the
gospel by Mark yeah does that make any
sense yeah Luke does that in a different
way in the beginning of Acts he writes
in my first volume I told all that Jesus
began to do and say and so he puts it
overtly there yeah I think I think that
fit your your reading on mark fits what
he's up to because we'll see in the end
that things don't wrap up all together
at the end of 16 chapters that there's
still a lot left for disciples and for
successive generations to do okay so
let's let's watch for that and see if we
see hints along the way that we're along
the way we're not at the end of the
story by the time we get to the end of
the story at the end of this story is
not the end of the gospel for mark right
so let's go back to the to the verses
we've said we're gonna focus on for this
discussion which are that's first
healing and then there's those second
healing where he begins to get
opposition in chapter 3 what's going on
in those two well they bracket this
section and mark wants them to because
in one 21 to 28 we get Jesus walking
into a synagogue and a man comes up to
him who has a demon and Jesus casts out
the demon and then people respond as
they respond in 3 1 to 6 it's the next
time Jesus in a synagogue and mark says
again he was in the synagogue as if to
say you remember that time here we are
while ago here we are in and this time
guy walks up to him he heals him so
so far a lot the same but then the
response rather than general amazement
as it was in Chapter one is the
Pharisees extreme ire and attempt to
plot his demise yeah right they they
challenged him in the moment asking why
are you doing this on the Sabbath and
then at the end of the passage the
narrator tells us that they had often
tried to try to plot his undoing there
and and so the puzzle that that presents
itself in these first chapters is is in
this comparison which is why given all
the good that Jesus is doing to the
people in the countryside and you know
in the towns of Galilee why aren't they
presenting with some kind of metal or
your honor rather than upset why are
they coming at him with opposition and
it seems to me that the clue is in this
meteoric rise in his popularity because
at some point it becomes a professional
rivalry I think and at one level that's
fun in a story way right it it gives
characters motive and but on another
level it starts I think a process of
realizing that these characters are
built and and that we can participate we
can see ourselves in the characters and
and kind of get ourselves into the
action because it's a real story being
posed it's not just a collection of
Jesus stuff so when we get ourselves
into the action do we choose who our
characters are or do we say ah that's me
I'm the opposition or I'm the disciple
around the the the demoniac the person
with a demon who needs to be healed does
it work in that kind of let me invite
you to place yourself in the story yeah
yeah and I think there is along with
that so so if someone is getting healed
I think we can see ourselves in the
place of a person who's being helped by
Jesus who can choose that role yeah when
we get to the Pharisees in this case the
Pharisees or the Jewish leaders
generally in mark there's almost a
melodramatic over painting here so so I
don't know anybody who's ever wanted to
choose Pharisee is right right very
right and so it so they end up sort of a
straw character in a way out against
which Jesus is revealed as
is right and they serve a not a straight
man but as a sort of foil yeah
which which it doesn't allow us to to be
those people but allows us to see Jesus
relative to them and also to be a part
of the crowd assessing what's going on
yeah yeah I think I think one of the
tricky things for reading mark today for
reading any of the Gospels today is some
sense that that we take those kind of
foil strawperson characters from the
first century and say ah that's what it
is to be a Jewish leader you know rabbis
that's who those rabbis are they're the
ones who are out to get us and to get
him and and that becomes a terrible
citizenship not very good Christianity
and finally not very good reading of the
text because we're simply translating
people who are there in some ways for
literary reason as if that was a good
description of what Judaism was either
then or now yeah I mean we're in an age
of Christopher Hitchens and Richard
Dawkins and sam harris and neo atheists
who are looking at that part of
christian history and saying the abuses
of christianity namely in some cases
strong anti Judaism yeah strong
anti-semitism are what discredit saw and
they find their their material in
characterizations like this right anti
Judaism can find it's or anti-semitism
can find its material and in these but I
have a hard time holding mark culpable
for that just we're dealing with a
Jewish author about Jewish people and a
Jewish hero and Jewish Foyle's in the
course of history that gets made into
something else yeah I think and if we
think about the foil and the way the
melodrama works that helps a lot I
wouldn't actually trust the Native
American reading of the of the Cowboys
because they're genuinely annoyed with
good reason but the Cowboys and vice
versa I certainly don't trust the
Cowboys reading of Native Americans
because there was a feud going on and
neither one actually presents history
and any very careful or clear way what
about this demons thing all right here's
our first healing a man hasn't even know
yes man has a demon what in the world is
that and how do we talk about that in
the 21st century yeah and one of one of
the sort of larger matters in which that
produced
it says what do we do with miracles
Aaron Larkin we'll get to that yeah but
I mean this has been called everything
from epilepsy to clear demon possession
you get most scientific minds dismissing
this as something pretty much every day
as mental illness you get some
scientific minds saying this could be a
phenomenon in our time yeah but in in
the story it's clear that part of Marc's
way of presenting Jesus is that he's
going to free people from the demonic
world yeah it's it starts in 1:21 but it
doesn't stop there we're gonna other
passages along the way it's going to
come back and the the the drama will
build as Jesus continues to confront
demons and they'll become more colorful
stories even as it goes on so it's clear
to to any reader of Mark that that that
spirit world is a part of what Jesus
came to confront yeah well it's all it's
been helpful to me as a teacher in
seminaries to meet students from other
parts of the world so that what we think
is a clear 21st century understanding of
what's old-fashioned mythology for them
is a live vital way of talking about
their experience and that we can learn
from people for whom that way of talking
is not antiquated or quaint but the way
in which they deal with pastoral
oppression cycle ah what we would call
psychological distress so I I would find
myself in some ways wanting to revive
our understanding of the way in which
people can be in thrall of powers that
are beyond their understanding and there
are different ways of talking about it
but the reality is not just some quaint
old-fashioned first century thing I
think you're right and I think any
chance we get to be relieved of our
bondage to the Enlightenment in this
area is a helpful tool a reason aside
right means that we we condition our
position in the world we say maybe it
doesn't have all the answers and and we
allow ourselves to listen to cultures in
which there are live options that we've
dismissed long ago let me try this on
you the kind of summary of what we've
got going in chapter
to the beginning of chapter three that
you've got a duel you've got dueling
authorities you've got the authority of
the demonic world you've got the
authority of the synagogue
you've got the authority of the people
who will ask in Chapter two why Jesus
thinks he can forgive sins and you've
got this different authority which turns
out to be God's own authority this guy's
been baptized by John
this guy's heard this guy Jesus our Lord
and Savior it's heard a voice saying you
are my son he has forgiven sins he has
healed people he is gathering her crowd
and at some point we're beginning to say
who is this this is is this someone in
whose authority we can trust and I think
Mark is setting it up so that becomes a
question not just for some original
audience and certainly not just for the
first disciples but for his first
hearers and also for us hearing it all
these years later right right and and we
haven't heard it asked out loud yet but
we will we will or as who is this and it
will be so you're right they've mark has
set the table for that question
but nobody's asking yet so we're almost
waiting for the other artist so let's
let's see how it follows through the
screen thank you